I'm super Thomas but Wolfram research I
will be presenting the design of line
following robot and the deployment to
this Zoomer robot using the
microcontroller
so hello and welcome to this talk this
this Zoomer robot from Pololu is going
to be the centerpiece of my talk so I'll
highlight the sensors and actuators that
you're going to use to do the line
following so in the front of this robot
is a sensor module so that is six
infrared LED and photo transistor pairs
that can that can determine the position
of this robot with respect to that line
and then the motor and then the robot
also has two DC motors to indicate
independently control the left and right
wheels so this Arduino Uno that is faced
down on the robot is the microcontroller
the newer models have the atmega 32 u4
and arc it will also work with with that
version so let me start off with the
mathematical model the orientation of
the robot with respect to the line is
denoted by theta so the objective of the
controller is to keep theta 0 and the
speed the angular velocity of the left
and right wheels are fee L and fee R we
can we can get a kinematic relationship
between these three quantities with some
elementary calculations so if I hold the
left wheel fixed fee L is zero then the
velocity of this right motor shaft is
going to be our fee R where R is the
radius of the wheel in terms of Tara
that is also because the rope when when
this wheel is rotating the robot will be
rotating about that track is also 2 x yd
/ yd is just all offset and theta R
prime so theta R is Theta just due to
the rotation of the right wheel and we
can do something similar for the left
wheel - and we get a similar
relationship except that this time we
have to have the negative sign because
this wheel is going to push theta in the
opposite or in the negative direction so
the net angular velocity of the robot
theta prime is just the sum of those two
terms and we end up with this kinematic
relationship
if the two velocities are the same then
the robot is not rotating so I'll go
ahead and decompose these speeds as a
common base speed fee and differential
component so once I do that we get what
we expect that Tara dot just depends on
the differential speed so this is a
linear model so I can put this into a
state space representation and it just
depends on this ratio R / yd so I'll
convert this into a state space
representation and and substitute the
numerical values for these parameters so
next let's look at the controller design
for the differential input so the
controller is first a tracking tracking
controller we want Tara to be zero it is
also a disturbance rejection because the
disturbance comes from the track and we
want the controller to negate that so
what I'll do is for robustness I'll also
add an integrator to the model so the
controller will not only regulate Tara
it will also bring the integral of of
theta to zero and this model is both
controllable and observable so I can
design a set of feedback gains and
estimated and estimate against so these
values I have here for the poles of the
regulator and estimator you typically
get them by trial and error so that's
where this functionality comes in useful
you can iterate with different values
and deploy it and see how the controller
is is doing so once I have those gains I
can construct the controller using
estimator regulator that will put
that'll put the whole controller
together so it takes the integral of
theta as the input and the differential
the integral of theta as the input and
the differential controller as the
output so let's go ahead and verify this
controller I'm creating a small utility
function that will just put systems in
series so this is the overall structure
of the of the whole system so the
reference typically is zero in this case
so we compare that with the actual
orientation of the
and that goes through an integrator and
the estimator regulator and the control
input is fed into the robot at the other
end there is the line axis of
disturbance and then the sensor reads
the updated position and that's how the
controller works so let's compute that
loop gain so there are two there are two
inputs so there are two closed-loop
systems one from one from this reference
to theta so that's the first system and
then there is also the other system
going from the disturbance to theta so
what we can verify is whether the poles
of these closed-loop system are the
regulator and estimator poles that we
started with so we can look at the
frequency response of this closed-loop
system and we see that for the for the
first transfer function for the first
system that is from the reference you
see it tracks well and the other system
is attenuated so basically the
disturbance is getting rejected and the
system is tracking it seems to be good
all the way up to three radians per
second or close 270 degrees per second
it can it seems to be doing both so we
can also do some time domain simulations
so this one I'm just arbitrary giving it
some inputs you see if I ask you to
track a particular input we see that has
some minimal overshoot and takes about
half a second to settle down you can do
excuse there's a step response yeah
you're just doing yeah we can all be you
can do the same thing with the
disturbance input and whatever
disturbance we give you see again it
takes about half a second to bring the
orientation back to zero and we can do
yet another simulation with a different
initial condition so if you look at
these closed-loop systems the fourth
state is actually the output or the or
theta so we are interested in in this
food plot and again you seen after about
half a second the system settles down
now once we have this closed loop system
I'm going to extract the controller out
of the
so I can I can deploy it so for the
controller so what is feeding into the
controller is the theta the angle
measurement and it needs to track zero
so we are not you we are not measuring
this reference from anywhere it's just
implicit so because it's part of the
system the way we I model it is we have
a gain block of gain negative one and
then it passes through the integrator
and then the estimator regulator and out
comes the differential input I have an
additional block here that that converts
the units from radians per second to
rotations per minute that's because I'm
eventually going to use a library which
uses the units in in in rotations per
minute so this is the controller in
continuous time and so to implement it
on the microcontroller we discretize it
to get the discrete-time controller so
again the sampling period is is a design
parameter you play with it until you get
a good a good result okay
so at this point we have we have figured
out how to how to get the differential
controller input now the speed also
depends on a on the on the base speed or
the common fee so if it is zero the
robot will not move forward we could
have an arbitrary value and then get the
robot to go around the track at a
constant speed but we could also borrow
a lesson from our driving experience and
then slow up Oh speed the robot based on
how how sharper turn it needs to take so
what I have here it's basically telling
if the if theta is small then the speed
is going to be very high and then if
it's so if it's a very large deviation
to basically slow it down now if I
implement this as is what I saw was that
at these transitions the robot will
accelerate and decelerate very rapidly
and then those transitions will become
very conspicuous conspicuously jarring
so what I did was passed this output
through I just average the output and
then past passed it through a low-pass
filter
okay so to summarize what what I have
now is a differential is a differential
controller input which takes the
orientation and computes the
differential input and also the blocks
to compute the forward speed so at this
point from here I can compute both the
left and right wheel speeds as fee plus
Delta and fee minus Delta
on the other side I need theta now the
sensor is not waiting theta it's reading
what's called a position value so I need
a model that will take the sensor
reading and compute theta okay so I'm
using the library that is provided by
the by the vendor to get this sensor
reading so because we're using the
library it's it's not that relevant to
look at the inner workings of the sensor
itself you just understand the library
and see how to use that for our purposes
so I'll quickly go with this and see it
quickly go over this because this is the
same process we'll be using when we
actually integrate this library with the
deployed code so we create a an object
of type the Zumo reflectance sensor
array we initialize it and then for
about 10 seconds we calibrate this when
the calibration happens I'm going to be
removing this robot across the track so
it gets a good look at what is the dark
line and what is the surrounding space
and then finally we we print out the
individual sensor values and the
position let me quickly run this and get
a sense of what the values are that are
coming out okay I'm just going to slide
it across the track so that the sensors
can get calibrated
okay so now all the sensors are reading
0c now the first now just the first
sensor that's the one here is above the
track and you see this first value pick
it up and as I keep moving that you'll
see the second sensor pick it up and
there is an algorithm they have to get
this net position value and as I keep
going you'll see the next sensor come up
and there and the first sensor go to
zero all the way till the till the fifth
sensor so these positions as the robot
is is moving about this track you got to
convert to an angled position so so that
that is so I've already done that and
and got this data for different angles
what are the readings and it looks
almost linear so I do I create a fitted
model and use that model and use that
fit as the model for my sensor so this
model basically takes the raw sensor
reading and converts it into an angle so
once I have that block I can complete I
can construct the complete controller
using the system's connection model we
just connects this individual subsystems
so
this point I have the complete
controller so what is left is to connect
these this controller to the actual
input and output pins of the robot and
I'm going to do that using these
libraries so the function we used the
function we used to deploy the code is
microcontroller embed code so this
function takes three arguments the first
one is the system's model of the
controller we have that and the last one
is the is the connection mechanic
mechanism or how we get the controller
from our machine onto the on to the
target and because that is an Arduino
Uno it's very simple actually we specify
what is the serial port and so that's
also taken care of what's left is the
second argument which are the
microcontroller specifications it is in
this second argument that we say what is
the name of the microcontroller what are
the pins that are being used how to
configure these pins and so on and but
because I'm going to use the library I'm
not going to do that myself I will just
configure the library and get the
library took to take care of the pins
and to get the data so you'll see that
no yet you'll see that how we are going
to do that but before that I just want
to mention that when we are specifying
library code we just directly inject
code into various segments of the of the
code look at that
so to inject this library code we have
to understand what we understand
something about the library and that's
what I did with that with that sensor
code so we have to do that for all the
other components that we used that we
want to use and so I've already done
done that this is for the sensor this is
for the motor and this is for the button
so I mean I'm going to use the button so
so I get some time to actually unhook
the unhook the robot from the machine
before I send it off so for each these
are the header files that I should be
using from the library these are the
objects that I should create these these
are the functions that I'm going to be
used
in the initialization routine and these
are the functions in the loop so I I
start by by declaring all the all the
header files what are the objects I'm
going to be using and then it is the
initialization code so in the
initialization code what I'm doing is
first I'm initializing the sensors as
before and then I'm waiting for the
button to be pushed before I can send
the robot off and then this this code is
basically calibrating the sensors
earlier I manually moved the robot
across the track but Here I am getting
the robots to the motors just to swivel
the robot about the track so so so it's
automating that process of moving the
robot across the track and finally I'm
bringing them the I'm setting the motor
speeds to zero back again and finally I
get to the the part where the code needs
to run in a loop and this this is where
the controller inputs are actually
getting coupled to to the library inputs
library code and eventually to the pins
of the robot so we declare the type of
these inputs and outputs to be of X of
type external library and in the inputs
the last element of this list is what
will get coupled to the input of the
controller so in this case the function
we are using this read line and that is
going to get coupled to the input of the
controller if you look above you'll see
the input of the controller is the sense
of reading and so that is what is going
to come into the controller and in the
controller itself that sensor reading
goes into that block and converts it
into the actual angle something similar
also for the outputs the the usage is
the same except that in the outputs it's
the first element in the loop that gets
assigned to the output so the so I have
this variable called SPD so the first
output here is the differential speed so
that output of the controller gets
assigned to that variable and the second
one gets assigned to the common speed
and
then this one actually goes ahead in the
library and sets the motor speed so once
I have that then I can define the
microcontroller specifications basically
the name of the microcontroller what are
the files to include input outputs etc
and now I'm ready for deployment okay so
now I have the controller I have the
microcontroller specifications I also
have the port through which the
microcontroller is connected to the to
the machine and there's an additional
optional argument in a microcontroller
embed code and that is relevant because
we over here because we are using
external libraries we need to specify
the path to the external library so the
so the compiler doesn't balk when it
sees the sees the library code okay so
I'm going to deploy it
oh it's pretty hard to get the whole
thing on the camera it's going to just
catch it but when expressing by it I
guess